coin chamlou merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors tout d'abord
comment analysez-vous la déclaration de
mike pompéo annonçant que les états unis
vont désormais assimilé le boycott
d'israël à de l'antisémitisme
bonsoir merci de m'avoir invité
comment assimilés ça c'est pas vraiment
être au nom du tout puisque depuis
l'élection du président de la trempe et
surtout depuis l'arrivée du mac en pot
au secrétariat d'état
les etats-unis n'ont pas cessé d'en fait
d'accepter toutes les demandes
israéliennes
ils ont commencé tout d'abord par sortir
du de l'accord nucléaire iranien ensuite
ils ont accepté que jérusalem soit
reconnue comme la capitale éternelle
d'israël à la suite de ça ils ont
transféré l'ambassade américaine de tel
aviv d'un jérusalem puis ensuite ils ont
reconnu le plateau du golan commun
l'annexion du plateau du golan et
ensuite ils ont reconnu que les colonies
israéliennes étaient plus contraires au
droit mais l'américain est aujourd'hui
ils ont accepté que en fait donc tous
les produits qui ont été faits dans les
territoires occupés soient étiquetés
made in israël et non plus mes idées de
les territoires occupés et ils ont à la
suite de sa accepté de dire que si vous
ne reconnaissez pas ça vous êtes des
antisémites
c'est la connaissait la continuité de
cette politique américaine de train qui
est tout pour israël
quel est l'objectif de ces décisions
justement alors l'objectif de cette
décision ça va dépendre
est-ce que c'est assez pour transformer
en pot puisque si vous tout le monde le
sait - pompéo souhaite se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle en 2024
et pour cela il se rend dans les dents
dans les territoires occupés et c'est
une première pour un secrétaire d'état
américains de se rendre dans les
territoires occupés ainsi que dans le
plateau du golan
c'est il essaie de motiver les chrétiens
évangélistes pour avoir leurs voeux lors
dès lors des primaires républicaines qui
vont se dérouler en 2001 qu'un tour
pouvoir devenir président de président
des états unis
mike fontenot c'était quelqu'un de très
ambitieux il a fini premier de north de
ses études à l'école militaire
il est devenu ensuite en cristal un
député au congrès américain très vite il
est devenu directeur du ssiré puis
secrétaire d'état américain et ils ne
savent qu'ils ne souhaitent pas
s'arrêter ici il veut devenir président
des états unis et il souhaite avoir les
vôtres de tous ces chrétiens
évangélistes pour pouvoir accéder à
cette à ce poste
et qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre comme
réaction de la part de la palestine
alors mende run enfin je pense que de la
part de la panacée on peut pas on peut
rien à la juste à se dire qu'ils sont
outrés le premier ministre palestinien a
dit justement aujourd'hui qu'on pouvait
pas conduire des élections et donc on ne
pouvait pas conduire d une politique
étrangère en savourant des verres de vin
puisqu'il s'est vendu à dents dans une
exploitation vignolles et les et des
palestiniens ont beau protester mais
pour l'instant ils ne peuvent rien faire
puisque à cette date l'administration
américaine et grâce à un break ton pot
est totalement et entièrement pour les
colonies israéliennes
et vous avez vu que mike pompéo et
l'administration américaine a réussi à
forcer la main de quelques pays arabe à
signer des accords de paix avec israël
sans un parti sans la participation des
palestiniens donc à ce jour ils ne
peuvent rien faire et mike on perd au
lieu de conduire à ce jour donc de gérer
la politique étrangère normalement
jusqu'à ce que la nouvelle
administration entre en fonction il
essaie de fermer d'en fermer
l'administration byden pour des actes
pour lesquels ils ne peuvent plus
revenir en arrière alors toujours en
moyen orient vous l'évoquiez tout à
l'heure les états unis
ont également réactivé leurs sanctions
contre l'iran après être sorti de
l'accord de vienne sur le nucléaire
est ce qu'on peut parler d'une stratégie
de la terre brûlée dans la région de la
part de donald trump qui malgré ses
dénégations va bientôt quitter la maison
blanche
c'est exactement ça c'est vraiment une
politique de terre brûlée puisque ils
font en fait de la même chose dans leurs
relations étrangères que ce qu'ils font
pour les élections présidentielles il a
perdu les élections présidentielles il
fait des procès par tous sens et en
permettant sûr qu'il peut pas gagner il
fait la même chose
là maintenant actuellement en iran il
est sorti de cette de cet accord gagnant
gagnant
et aujourd'hui il impose de nouvelles
sanctions sur le bonne yann safin poussé
cette association de déshérités de
projets iraniens qui est là qu'est
l'association la plus puissante de la
fondation pour la plus puissante d'iran
il impose de nouvelles sanctions mais
qu'est ce que ça va donner
pratiquement rien puisque cette
administration va sortir et
l'administration de biden va les
remplacer même si à ce jour avec pompey
on n'a toujours pas reconnu le jogging
comme le président élu des etats unis
mais à ce jour ils essayent de faire feu
de tout bois pour voir ce qu'est ce qui
peut blesser et comment ils peuvent
empêcher l'administration by day est de
continuer ou de changer les choses
pour conclure peut-être une dernière
question sur ce boycott
pourquoi ce boycott a des moyens
finalement de protestation les plus
pacifiques semble-t-il faire si peur aux
israéliens est alors puissant allié
américain
puisqu'en fait vous avez la communauté
internationale ne re soutien plus ou
moins souri et dit ce qu'on fait vous
savez l'administration française ont
pris une décision en disant que des
produits qui sont faits dans les
territoires occupés doivent être
étiquetés produits des colonies
israéliennes
il y a eu un recours devant la cour
européenne 2
la cour de justice européenne la cour de
justice européenne a donné raison à la
france d'avoir choisi ce mode de
fonctionnement pour que ces produits
soient étiquetés produits à des
territoires des territoires israéliens
mais l'administration américaine étant
la plus puissante en disant on va mettre
made in israël ils savent que les
produits qui vont aller aux états unis
et donc ils ont pris cette décision
aujourd'hui même
cela va aider ni sera israël avant de
ces produits est également avant tous
ces produits qui part de ses colonies
tout en étant pour les américains qui ne
connaissent pas grand chose en fait de
ce qu'il est ce qui est la politique
internationale a acheté les produits
rendent en se disant oui samedi serait
ça ne vient pas des territoires occupés
sahel israël et comme je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est que le président
entrant et mike pompéo font à peu près
tout ce que leur demande le problème
nice natation
merci beaucoup corps chamoux d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat